tenemos varias estructuras moleculares
por nombrar así que fijémonos en esta
primera de aquí entonces como nos damos
cuenta no tenemos ninguna estructura
cíclica así que este es un arcano verdad
porque todos son enlaces simples así que
primero tenemos que encontrar la cadena
con más grupos verdad la cadena más
larga y que tenga más grupos es decir si
empezamos a contar por aquí por ejemplo
tendríamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 hasta
este punto verdad si nos vamos por abajo
tendríamos 11 12 13 y si nos vamos por
arriba tendríamos 11 12 y 13 así que
tenemos dos cadenas de 13 carbonos así
que de estas dos cadenas que son las más
largas tenemos que elegir las que tengan
más grupos al kilo
en esa cadena por supuesto mientras más
tengamos quizás al menos vamos a poder
garantizar que son más simples verdad
entonces si nos fijamos en esta cadena
de abajo veremos que sólo tendríamos un
grupo al que lo que correspondería
digamos a este de aquí verdad si
elegimos esta cadena de 13 sólo
tendríamos 1 mientras que si elegimos
esta cadena de por aquí está así
tendríamos dos grupos verdad tendríamos
este y este así que vamos a elegir
justamente esta cadena y déjenme
marcarla con otro color déjenme
marcarlas digamos con rojo ok entonces
esta es la cadena más larga que nos
vamos a tomar justamente porque tiene
más grupos al kilo ramificándose y estos
son más simples de verdad entonces este
de esta molécula ahora la vamos o más
bien esta cadena largas vamos a enumerar
la de tal suerte que nos encontremos al
grupo al kilo de forma más rápida y
sería empezar de este lado verdad
3 porque aquí está en el tercer carbono
nuestro primer grupo al kilo mientras
que si empezamos de este lado pues sería
hasta dentro de mucho verdad así que
seguimos la enumeración 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 y 13 así que este este esta cadena
larga nos dice que el nombre sería tree
decano tri decano porque tiene 13 13
átomos de carbono ahora bien qué es lo
que tenemos pues tenemos un grupo metil
aquí este es un metal este perdón es un
grupo metilo aquí le vamos a llamar 3
metil verdad un tres metil porque está
en el tercer átomo de carbono y en la
parte de abajo en esta en esta parte de
abajo tenemos un grupo propio y lo que
es de tres átomos de carbono y está
unido al cuarto así que a éste le vamos
a llamar el 4 propio verdad
ahora bien para dar el nombre completo
necesita necesitamos elegir cuál va
primero en orden alfabético
en orden alfabético la m o la p así que
es la m verdad así que finalmente el
nombre completo de esta molécula sería 3
metil 4 propio 4 propio tree decano y
por supuesto esto hay que escribirlo
junto a guardar tree decano y decano
entonces ya tenemos el nombre para esta
primera molécula vámonos ahora al
siguiente ejemplo aquí si tenemos una
estructura cíclica así que tenemos que
encontrar cuál es la digamos la
estructura más grande que podemos
encontrar por ejemplo aquí tenemos una
cadena de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 carbonos
mientras que el grupo digamos esta
estructura cíclica tiene 123456789 así
que nuestra estructura más grande es
justamente este ciclo este ciclo y que
por tener 9 carbonos sería 1
digamos que sería ciclón o la no verdad
porque es un es un anillo de nueve
átomos de carbono y puros enlaces
simples entonces este este estudio una
vez vamos a irlo identificando es el
ciclo no nano
aquí esta es una verdad ahora bien
antes de poder decir cuál es cuál de
estos grupos alquilo va a ir primero
vamos a tratar de ubicarlos muy bien
entonces este que tenemos aquí que estoy
marcando con azul tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
átomos de carbono verdad entonces este
es un grupo estilo y que se va a llamar
útil ahora bien este es un grupo propios
de los comunes big verdad este es un
propio o que iba a llevar el nombre
propio mientras que en este de acá
justamente tenemos un una ramificación
de cuatro átomos de carbono verdad pero
dispuesto de una forma muy curiosa
entonces este átomo de carbono es
terciario y por lo tanto podemos
garantizar que este es un ser útil
verdad e intente hacerlo esto digamos en
itálicas porque en algunos libros sobre
todo si estás considerando libros en
inglés te puedes encontrar que te vienen
itálica
muy bien
cuál sería la forma de asignarle el
nombre a esta molécula pues vamos a
tomar la primera porque necesitamos
empezar a enumerar en algún lado y vamos
a empezar justamente en aquel en aquel
grupo al kilo que que tenga la letra o
digamos por orden alfabético es decir
nos consideramos la b porque ya sabemos
que la terna lo vamos a omitir
consideramos la p y la h entonces
pensamos cuál es cuál es la que va
primero la del ape o la h y por supuesto
es la vez así que empezamos a enumerar
en este muy bien y recuerden que el
tener el el sec el de el tri todos esos
se eliminan digamos sólo cuando es eso
es cuando se considera verdad no se
puede por ejemplo podríamos considerar
que tener está separado justo por este
guión entonces vamos a empezar enumerar
de en este carbono y vamos a darle un
orden dependiendo de donde es donde
podemos encontrar el primer grupo al
kilo y en este caso sería
verdad en este sería el siguiente grupo
alquiló y por lo tanto sería el átomo 2
luego 3 4 5 6 7
8 y 9 entonces ya podemos concluir cómo
sería el nombre de esta molécula verdad
tenemos en el primer átomo de carbono
tenemos un hunter déjenme ponerlo bien
tenemos un
pero útil
bien luego tenemos en él
quizás debería hacerlo con más cuidado y
en realidad lo puse primero porque
habíamos dicho que era la primera letra
de todas estas ramificaciones que
teníamos ahora si nos damos por orden
alfabético seguiría la h verdad seguiría
la h
y este se encuentra en el quinto átomo
de carbono de nuestro ciclo de 9
carbonos entonces en el 5 vamos a tener
un reptil verdad y sólo nos resta poner
el propio y el que se encuentra en el
átomo número 2 entonces tendremos 22
propia y verdad propia 2 propia tenemos
un grupo propio en el átomo 2 y
terminamos con un ciclo no nano verdad
ciclo
no nan y ahí tienen el nombre verdad
simplemente nos está diciendo en el
primer átomo de carbono pueden encontrar
un termo til en el quinto átomo de
carbono un grupo ept y lo verdad es
decir 5 steel en el segundo átomo de
carbono un propio y finalmente la
estructura principal es un ciclón o nano
y ahí lo tienen hemos terminado